let's discuss this now with Alex Wilde
from the Taxpayers Alliance and Janet
Davis chief executive of the Royal
College of nurses Alex I start with you
as John Craig was saying there the
firefighters have been offered two
percent is it inevitable that the dam is
gonna burst now and that you're gonna
see lots of other plus 1% Awards I'm not
really sure I mean we've got to be
realistic about the state that the
public finances are in we're about 1.8
trillion in the red or borrowing six and
a half million pounds every single
minute every single hour rather but what
I would say is I do think this
highlights pretty much how stupid the
way in which we conduct these these kind
of pain ago she ations as in Whitehall
we have basically nationalized pay
bargaining and this leads to some public
sector workers in very poorer parts of
the country so for instance the
Northeast being relatively overpaid
crowding out the private sector in the
process we also end up with people work
in the public sector in more expensive
places like London being relatively
underpaid and as Janet will tell you
this is quite bad especially for things
like NHS Trust because they struggle to
compete in the labour market in London
they have to hire in more agency staff
agency staffs much more expensive it's
bad for Workforce Planning and it's
actually really quite bad for health
outcomes as well so I do think that
there is a case for sort of pay
increases for some parts of the public
sector especially actually nurses in
high-cost areas but I don't think that
we can afford across-the-board pay
increases I mean nurses are think it's
about three hundred and fifty thousand
nurses about 120 thousand police
officers about forty thousand
firefighters there's only about 10% of
the public sector workforce I mean are
we seriously saying that we think that
you know council press officers and
council social media officers all
desperately deserve a pay increase as
well but surely the point is though
every single worker in the public sector
has had a real terms pay cut since 2010
don't they deserve a pay rise well
there's been a bit of a correction
really because once upon a time it was
the case that the public sector received
very generous defined benefit pension
schemes in return for being paid less
this sort of changed quite a lot in in
the 2000s and there's still a pay
premium in the public sector actually
once you account for things like the
size of the employer
gender age qualifications people in the
public sector is still paid about 2%
more than people in the private sector
and that's before you count things like
pensions which are much much more
generous in the public sector okay Janet
what do you make of that I mean that is
a point I mean the average public sector
pays I think 505 pounds a week in the
private sector it's 464 pounds a week
and that's even before you take into
account the fact that public sector
pensions are more generous if we compare
the salary of nurses against other
graduates their earnings and their
earning potential is much less so that
isn't actually the case for nurses at
all there are some nurses who can get
onto those highest salaries but the
average nurse is earning nothing like
their colleagues in the private sector
and actually what's what we're seeing
now because we're seeing people leave
nursing so for the first time we know
that the more nurses leaving the
register that means they're leaving
nursing entirely than there are coming
on so we've hit that crisis point and
the pain reviewed body for nurses
actually said and that's the health
service workers actually said that this
was unsustainable when they reported
earlier than this year and we're
certainly seeing lies becoming
increasingly difficult to staff our
hospitals and communities and we're
using very expensive Bank expensive
agency staff to supplement those 40,000
vacancies that we have that actually is
not economical in itself what did you
make of Alex's point that you should
have regional pipe organ in the public
sector I mean if you did that nurses in
places like London would would get a
huge pay boost you wouldn't get this
issue about having to put aside housing
for them and things like that there is
actually something within the agenda for
change which is the the pay scales in
which health service staff are paid
which does allow actually for more money
for those high-cost areas and selearis
and they also have recruitment and
retention premier we believe that it's
for the National Health Service there
should be a national salary it means
that there's easy to move people around
people can get jobs in any area for the
same sort of salary the other thing of
course is it might be beneficial to our
members but you know when we're in a
position we are at the moment with
40,000 vacancies we do see as we see in
other economies such America we find
that nurses get higher and higher and
higher as people compete for those stuff
and of course that's why London has that
higher rate of pay that's one of the
points that Jeremy Corbyn made today is
somehow other Teresa may manage the Russ
one and a half million billion pounds
for the DUP the optics of this don't
look very good for people like Janet's
members do they well no they certainly
don't but I mean that's that's modern
politics isn't them in politics is
largely an exercise in bribing people
with other people's money and the only
difference is this time it happened
after the election of then before the
election because we had a hung
parliament you I don't approve of these
kind of deals I think that taxpayers
completely resent it but it also you
know does show how unfair the sort of
funding formula is you know relatively
poor English regions do extremely badly
compared to places like Scotland because
of the Barnett formula the whole way in
which we I'm you know finance the home
nations is totally unfair and this just
further exacerbated it afraid we will
leave it there Johnny Davis Alex well
thanks for joining me both